if earth got close enough the side  nearest to the black hole would begin  stretching toward it  our atmosphere would start to be  vacuumed up and then huge chunks of the  earth would rip apart and follow suit  if earth managed to fall into the orbit  of the black hole  we'd experience tidal heating  the strong uneven gravitational pull on  earth would continuously deform the  planet this would generate a tremendous  amount of internal friction heating the  earth's core to disastrous levels  it would likely give rise to earthquakes  volcanoes and deadly tsunamis  eventually no matter what size it is  anything entering a black hole would be  ripped into a string of individual atoms  yeah good luck with that